okay
now um exam one
i mentioned this before i thought this
would be helpful to everyone
um what i did is uh put together
what i call a concept map and i will
post this here it is oh there's a
periodic table isn't that
lovely um this is what i put together
for you guys
um and i call it exam one concept map
now i'm not going to go through it now
but i wanted you guys to have sort of
the big picture
of what we've done this really is a
celebration
especially when you look at all of the
things that we've learned and how
they're all connected together and
that's what i wanted you guys to see
okay so look at this so here are on the
left here
are this is all not graded stuff here's
what's been graded oh and this is what's
graded on monday
exam one problem topics look at all
those things
now over here we have the three goodie
bags that you guys have had
and there have been problems in there
right and and here we have the
the problems that you've had from the
textbook right and the topics there
here you've had your seven recitations
here you've had it's even color-coded
it's even color-coded right so here
you've got the lectures so these are the
nine lectures and all the topics that
we've talked about
today is number 10 and as i said i will
tell you something today
about lewis structures right that will
not be on the exam
um and that is resident lewis structure
so we'll teach that
um and then those are the three quizzes
now you notice there's some things
like here okay we've covered this stuff
like lewis dots right
and electronegativity right lewis
structures stuff like that we've covered
that has not been on a quiz but it could
be on the exam
okay so this is a concept map that i
hope gives you a sense
of how this all connects together right
and how this connects together
to give you the knowledge
that you need to answer questions about
these topics
about these topics right now the exam is
not you know
these exams walk the balance
um we want you to learn
how to solve these problems these exams
what i want you to do on monday
is run out of knowledge not run out of
time
right so so did i get a snap thank you
right now now you might run out of both
but but listen
but
[Laughter]
but these are not meant to break you in
a speed test
these are meant to see if you have
learned the concept so what i
ask you to do on this exam is show us
what you know
right as you may know already
i am a big fan of partial credit lots of
partial credit if you show me you know
something
you will get credit yeah and so that
gets into also like exam strategies with
a lot of you already know about this
stuff but please remember like don't
don't just you know go in order and then
run out of time and not even see the
last two questions right take a look
tell me what you know show us what you
know okay
we're not about like the last decimal on
some calculation i'm much more about do
you understand the concept do you know
how to solve this problem so show us
that
please on the exam okay now
um was that another loud snap in favor
is that
i think that means it's like positive
reinforcement um
now okay topics now okay so like
the other thing i want to say about the
exam okay
is you know we're going to connect
concepts together sometimes that's the
point
right exams aren't just going gonna be
another three quizzes
plus one more question on lewis right
no we're gonna see if you can also weave
together
the knowledge right so an example would
be if i were to ask you
okay i'm gonna give you a pes
and okay so let's see here would be like
a
a question about a pes uh question so
here's a pes diagram
and here i'm gonna draw i'm gonna say
okay i give you
this pes here we go let's let's label it
three
four five six we don't need more than
that
okay so we're going to go oh and a break
in the axis
now you know all about that and we're
going to go all the way up to six here
right and we'll do another break we'll
go up to two there
and now this is going to go up to here
okay and you can read off of here that's
the number remember with the ps that's a
relative electron count
how many electrons are i'm blasting this
this atom with
with enough photon energy gazentite to
get all the electrons out and then i'm
counting their relative
right how i measure the kinetic energy i
can get the energy oh by the way this
would be like
decreasing right
the way i plotted it before and the way
we usually plot
pes diagrams is the x-axis is going down
in energy right because these are those
are the 1s
electrons there and these would be the
2s
these would be the 2p right and i can
keep on going so i've got
3s now what do we got here we've got 3
p how many four okay good
so what what's that okay a question you
might be asking
what atom is that sulfur
okay good i say okay that's sulfur so i
can answer that kind of question
but now let's take another concept and
weave it in here right
so like okay if that's sulfur and say
well what if
i had what if i went up to chlorine
right so now sulfur has 16. sulfur has
16
and and chlorine is 17.
i said what would this look like for
chlorine
i gave you this well you might say well
i know
it's going to just be like this right
let's go to the right height and now i
filled that with the one more electron
and so it must be chlorine but that's
not taking everything you know into
account
that's not taking because you know that
if i go up to chlorine i've added a
proton
but i haven't really done much more to
shield
those outer electrons and so everything
wants to be closer to that more positive
charge so you've got to reflect that in
the pes right
so if i were really gonna say well now
you you know
you you might not even know
quantitatively but you know
qualitatively
if i'm gonna draw this peak for chlorine
it better be to the left
of that peak it's got to move in
just like the orbitals and all those
things you're talking about that's the
kind of thing that i mean
right i want you to be able to
synthesize concepts as we think about
exam questions okay everything's going
to shift over if you go to chlorine
all right
now on
on wednesday we talked about lewis
structure so let's talk about lewis
structures more uh let's suppose
i've got acetaldehyde a wonderful
toxic compound h4o
i said okay here's what i'm saying here
is a possible lewis structure
for this all right let's see i'm going
to draw the
the two carbons here here's my oxygen
it's got some lone pairs i'll put
another one there why not
hydrogen here and we got one more
hydrogen there
what is wrong with this
double bond on the hydrogen
all right the question really is what is
not wrong with this
i can count three things right now that
are wrong with this what are they
double bonded this has to have remember
right
these things need to be happy and follow
their octet
octet means for hydrogen too
right but otherwise now is this so
that's good
that's good that's not good right okay
so we're not is this good
no no
is that good all right
now hold on because so but okay but
there's something else that's
fundamentally wrong with this
anybody notice how many electrons
this is how you start a lewis problem
how many electrons do i have
how many electrons do i have remember
lewis is all about the valence
so i got four times two right that's
eight
right eight electrons four electrons
here and six electrons here
how many do i have twelve okay so i've
got eighteen electrons
total now what did i put into this
diagram okay
so each of these bonds remember a line
is two
electrons it's a bonding pair
right okay so i've got so i've got 2
4 6 8 10 12
14 16 18 20. i didn't even get the
electron count right
i didn't say it's acetaldehyde two minus
right so what wrong
number of electrons
and octets
not formed there's something else
there's another way you can see how this
lewis structure is wrong
how is that what else did we learn on
wednesday
really important concept formal charge
formal charges are all all over the
place
lowest not lowest
formal charge okay
now when i say lowest i mean
closest to zero because
that is what gives you the most stable
structure as we talked about on
wednesday you see this
formal charges here are are all over the
place right so the formal charge
on on on this carbon is okay so you go
the number of valence electrons of the
free atom
right minus dots minus six
right so four
minus one two three right so that's plus
one oh six minus one two three four
five six seven right so that would be
minus one so this is this is not a good
lewis structure for many
for all of these reasons the right lewis
structure
would look something like this very easy
fix
right and see
and here you go and now
you can check all of these things that
we just talked about you can check the
formal charge you can check the total
charge
right i could have taken two electrons
off of here and it still would have been
wrong
right but this is the right lewis
structure because we get we satisfy all
of the things
that we talked about on wednesday okay
good now
as i mentioned there's one other concept
the last concept that will not be on the
exam oh but it could be unlike the exam
two i don't know
um is the last concept about lewis
structures that's very important
and it's what happens when you have
structures that
look similar it's like
if i look at all these things number of
electrons octets forming
formal charges these look
good these both look good
and so the question is which one of them
is right
and this gets into this concept that i
want to
teach you which is called resonance
and just to define resonance i'll put
that on the board
these are called resonant structures
okay
now resonance
when referring to uh
lewis structures it the way i want you
to think about it is that it describes
delocalization haha i'm going all caps
delocalization
why not
i'm not shouting it i'm just saying it's
an important concept
describes delocalization right
of electrons
in molecules
so in the case of ozone which is
something we broke apart and talked
about
right we talked about ozone already
in the case of ozone now what's
happening well if i draw
if i draw the ozone molecule
the way let's see if i draw it the way
one of those is so i'll draw it the way
the left hand
picture is like this
and oh and i'm not talking about shape
no shape yet somebody said isn't it bent
i don't know
next week shape this week no shape
well okay hold on now um if i look at
this molecule
this is a double bond there's more
electrons on this bond
than here and what we know about that is
that that's going to make
that bond stronger and those atoms are
going to be closer so this
this length would actually be around 1.2
angstroms and this one would be around
1.5 ish
right but see and now you say well maybe
it's the other one
1.2 over here 1.5 over there but now i
take ozone and i can measure it
i can measure those bond lengths and i
do that
and when i do that what i find
is that it's neither of these right
so but in experiment
the bond length
is 1.3
and it's the same it's not different
so what is happening physically what is
happening
is delocalization and remember
electrons do things to be happy
happiness means lowering the energy of
the whole system
right and so what these electrons
realize
what these extra two electrons here
realize that okay okay i could make this
bond short and that bond long
but maybe if i delocalize across the
whole molecule
maybe if i do that i can be happier
meaning i can be in a lower energy state
and that is what resonance
talks about that is what it tells us
about it tells us when i have these
different states
that look equivalent that the molecule
essentially pictorially is going back
and forth between them so fast
that it's an average that it's a
delocalization
that those now the way that we
think about this in terms of our lewis
structures
is by having
one resonant form and another resonant
form
okay now hold on so here
uh okay let's do this and
this and double bond on this side
good and the way that
the you know chemists are very
particular about how you use arrows and
you have to be very careful
in chemistry about how but here's a case
where they really like the arrow
and they really like curvy arrows in
particular and what the curvy
arrow shows you is what happened
to the electrons so it's really just a
representation
of where the electrons went to get from
one resonant structure to another how
they
changed but it can be actually helpful
to understand whether you really have a
resonance structure
and what's happened so for example in
this case these are the two resonance
structures for ozone
right okay so what happened well to get
from this structure to this structure
you can see
what's happened is that uh okay these
this
you can imagine this lone pair has gone
on to that bond all right
and oh okay and um this bond
right this uh where am i this bond
has no this lone pair
has gone on to this bond okay right so
i've made a double bond
to get to there and i've made the double
bond here
to get to there now what's missing
well i've got to make the other lone
pair appear here from this bond right
so you can look at your resonance
structures and realize that that also
happened
right and you can look over here and
i've got three lone pairs on that
so the only way to get that would have
been let's draw these over here to make
room
if that happened those curvy arrows
help us just see how the changes in the
electrons happened
in these resonance structures but the
way to really think about this and this
is why
i wanted to draw i wanted to capitalize
this word
is that the actual structure is
a combination of these so let's see
i'll do this and the way you would write
the actual structure would be like this
okay this and
this and this
and dashed lines
oh and this is called
the resonant hybrid structure resonant
hybrid it's it's a mixture of the
structures and it shows
with the dashed lines the delocalization
and if you want to be complete
about this resonant structure concept if
you want to be complete
then you would also count formal charges
okay and so you would see that the
formal charge let me
make sure i get this right okay so over
here we've got what
six minus one two three four five six
seven right so the formal charge here
was minus one
okay the formal charge here six minus
one two three four
five all right so that's minus one nope
that's sorry plus one
in the middle okay and the formal charge
here is
six minus one two three four five six
right so that's zero
right and over here i'm not going to do
the counting again
it's the same but the zeros and the
minus ones have switched
as you can see right
now in the resonant hybrid structure
what's happened
notice these are the two lewis
structures so you're you know you do
have
you do have formal charge formal charges
are not zero ever
but that's okay this is the best you can
do
but you've got the two that are
equivalent and they go back and forth
and in this case the way you would draw
that is that you would have
the plus is still there but now you're
sort of sharing
the formal charge on the ends
so if you want to think about this in
terms of formal charge notice something
about formal charge
right i did not add or take away charge
in this case
i gotta add it up yeah the addition of
all formal
charges by the definition of formal
charge
must be equal to the charge on the
molecule
it must be so if
if this molecule is neutral then the
formal charge must add up to zero which
it does
right it does and it does good way to
check your work
okay okay so we can go further so that's
the concept of resonance and i did it as
i like to do
kind of slowly and now i'll give you
another example but i'm not going to go
through it as slowly
and um but oh let's ask this question so
if i had
the top thing okay so here's two other
cases now this one we're going to get
through quickly
is this a resonant structure and i'm
going to give you the answer the answer
is no
and the reason is that resonance
structures only involve
the curvy arrow motion of electrons
right the curvy arrows showing us how
electrons
might change in this but not of atoms
notice i cannot get from here
to here without moving an atom
that's not a resonance structure that is
not a resonance structure so we're done
with that
all right and we can put uh
well let's put a little thing here only
change
location of
electrons not
atoms let's keep this separate
okay not atoms all right but now we get
to another one where we didn't change
the location of atoms but we did change
the location of electrons
right um and and you can see the
structure up there
and i won't do this because i just did
it for ozone
but you can go through this yourself and
show
with curvy arrows what's happening
between these structures
these are three resonant structures
these are three resonance structures
okay
and you can see how they go right so you
can see like here
i had the extra lone pair on the oxygen
that might have a curvy arrow to here to
give you the double bond there
right but as i did that in order for
carbon to keep its formal charge
right to keep its formal charge i had to
take i had to do something with this
double bond
right and so this is how you think about
resonance structures and just to give
you the the final
for that one just show you what it would
look like once you've got
the hybrid structure it would look
something like this
okay so there
there and oxygen with its two lone pairs
and oxygen with its two lone pairs
and the delocalized electrons and then
you've got your charge
and this would be minus two-thirds
minus two-thirds minus two-thirds
notice on these on these three oxygen
atoms notice that
again okay the formal charge adds up
to the charge on the molecule there it
is charging the molecule that's a two
minus
right this is co3
two minus
formal charge adds up to the charge on
the molecule good
okay one more example because now we're
going to
combine this and learn one other
really important concept about lewis
structures
let's see if this yeah okay
so here's an example what do i have this
up here
no
here's an example what if i had the
thiocyanate ion this is a
favorite so this is c n
s minus this is a um
that's a draw write the name here thio
this is a favorite for demonstrating
concepts about lewis and you'll see why
in a minute
because first i'm going to draw a lewis
structure
this is a minus so it's an ion first i'm
going to draw a lewis structure that
seems to make sense but then as you'll
see
there are resonant lewis structures that
also seem to make sense so i need to use
some of the concepts we've learned to
figure it out right
so so if i draw this let's see i'm going
to draw three
so n triple bond c
sulfur lone pairs lone pair
or i could have n
double bond c double bond sulfur
lone pair lone pair or
try to squeeze this in underneath so you
can ah
put it here and three lone
pairs single bond c triple bond sulfur
now these are resonant structures i i
can get them by drawing my curvy arrows
and moving electrons around right um
but and so you might say well is this
not just going to be an
average is are these electrons
delocalized
according to their resonance structures
but see once we start thinking about
formal charge
we get more insight all right so the
formal charge here is minus two
five minus one two three four five six
seven
minus two right uh here it's zero
and here it's plus one
right sulfur six minus one two three
four
five okay good but that and so that
looks pretty bad right a large formal
charge
minus two okay over here oh i didn't
draw the lone pairs sorry about that
here's two lone pairs here
we will not mess up the electron count
again today
okay and so here the formal charge uh
let's see this one would be
minus one and in here it's zero
and over here it's zero that looks
better right according to my rules
on wednesday this looks like a more
stable structure than that
okay so even though it's resonant i'm
going to say that's probably not going
to be
part of the most stable ground state
structure but let's look at this last
one
zero and over here i've got zero
and over here i've got minus one oh
what do we do there's one last point
that we need to learn
and it has to do with the formal charges
and it's a general
rule in writing lewis structures and
that
is that let's see if i can fit it here
because it's very relevant to here
that atoms
with the
negative
formal charge
should be i'm not going to fit it here
should be on
the more
electronegative ion electroneg
atom not ion atom
okay so let's take a look and see what
this means let's understand it first
i just wrote something out let's make
sure we understand it right
so atoms with the with the negative
formal charge
should be on more electronegative atoms
that kind of makes sense right because
remember what our definition of
electronegativity is
electronegativity is the desire
of an atom to bring bonded pairs towards
itself
remember and it makes a molecule polar
polar covalent
for example maybe ionic but anyway it's
that desire to bring
bonded pairs towards itself so if if an
atom has a negative formal charge
right then you think well that should be
on the more electronegative atom because
the negative formal charge means it's
got a little bit
extra charge compared to when it was
free
okay and so if you look at this
oh now you need to know
electronegativities something that
we know the electronegativity of
of nitrogen so uh chi remember
of nitrogen is around 3.0
and chi for sulfur is around 2.5
and that tells us that this
is the ground state structure
okay all from the concepts we already
know
all from the concepts we already know
now at the same time
the atoms that are more electropositive
would want to have positive formal
charges in general
right so the same rule applies the other
way okay
okay now so that's that's the last uh
part of lewis structures
that i want you to know about and and it
all kind of
ties together you can see resonance this
is why this is such a great example you
can think about
resonance and could you move electrons
around and get different structures yes
but then those aren't actually
equivalent because they have very
different formal charges
okay and then two of them had kind of
similar-ish formal charges but one
is more stable because of of that okay
good now why does this matter and i'm
going to tell you
an example of why this matters
um i'm talking about delocalization
to stabilize and i'm talking about how
the actual structure of a molecule
isn't this sort of you know rigid
two bonds here one bond there that's not
what that says but it
it wasn't an ozone right but it's this
it's
this shared equivalent bonds where the
electron is shared and the whole system
is lowered now there is one molecule
where this is
uh very much important and dictates all
of its chemical behavior and that's
benzene
and in back in the day in the 1930s
um and oh by the way pauling right
electronegativity scale we talked about
him on wednesday
right but back in the day they didn't
know what benzene was they could kind of
measure some things but it didn't none
of it worked
and pauling wrote a number of structural
formula
have been proposed for benzene but none
of them is free
from very serious objections
well the way they wrote stuff right look
at these shapes for benzene
if we don't know the right shape and
why you have the right shape for benzene
then we cannot understand
you know all of the mega amounts of
organic chemistry
that we do with benzene right so this is
what's happening with benzene
you have these two structures that
benzene actually averages over
right these are resonant structures back
in the day
um they called them cacola structures
because cacola as you can see was kind
of close
and thought about this as well these are
resonant structures it totally dictates
the
chemistry of benzene which then leads to
massive amounts of things that we do
with benzene
because with benzene and this is just
you know we don't need to look at this
in detail it's just an example
of a few out of almost unlimited
variations of benzene that we can make
because we can take one of those
hydrogen atoms and put something on it
or two places and each time we do that
we get a different material a different
molecule
that gives us different properties and
different uses
okay and and it's but all of this
even though we draw it still with those
lines
we know that inside it's delocalized
right it's delocalized well it might
change once you add stuff to it but by
itself here
by itself here it's delocalized and that
sets up the properties of benzene
now okay let's go a little farther
i can draw okay so i like these last two
here okay there's uh was it naphthalene
right now you can keep on going
and keep adding benzenes and we're gonna
get somewhere that i really love
oh this is getting me excited
now oh look i'm gonna add one there i'm
just gonna keep adding benzene
um now i could stay here oh don't get
benzene wrong now i can keep going
and if i kept going i might get sheets
of benzene that are now called graphene
and if i stack those up i've got
graphite i've got graphite
that's what graphite is it's these very
large sheets of benzene now
there are two very well known phases of
pure carbon
one is diamond and the other is graphite
um does anybody know which one is more
stable
how many people think graphite how many
people think diamonds are forever
no i listen i'm very sure i've given you
guys some advice
especially like you know remember like
you're out and
maybe you're out on a date and it's the
weekend
and there's a candle and you've talked
about combustion
and you've written that down and you
talked about how long you have in that
room because you know about oxygen and
the limiting reagent
that it's either you or the candle we
talked about that we also talked about
how you need your periodic table on that
date
and how you may need your spectroscope
because
they might give you an led candle
instead you need to talk about leds
and i'm not saying that all of these
conversations involving knowledge you've
gained in this class
will lead to this place of seriousness
but it could lead to engagement
it could and now some people when they
get engaged one person buys the other
a ring and sometimes that involves this
material
my point to you right now is when you go
to the store
maybe it's tiffany's uh maybe it's
somewhere else and you buy that ring
ask for a warranty and make sure
it's about a hundred thousand years
because after
that time that ring is going to turn
into graphite because graphite
is the lowest stable most energetically
stable form of carbon
so i'm just again always trying to help
but this
this is the most stable form of carbon
and it's a bunch of benzene but repeated
right not benzene the hydrogens are gone
it's just pure graphene
but repeated in these beautiful rings
and when we come back to when we come
back to hybridization
and molecular orbitals which we'll start
after exam one
you'll see other beautiful properties of
structures like this
by the way speaking of seeing you can
see this material
right what are you throwing at this
material to see it like that
not light you're not not photons you're
throwing electrons
i just came across this the other day in
wired new microscope shows the quantum
world and crazy
they took electrons and they shined it
on these little particles of platinum
and iron
and they're able to literally see every
single atom as they break apart the
particle
under the by just throwing electrons out
and say the transmission electron
microscope was designed
to break records using its meaning of
electron scientists with many types of
viruses etc etc they got down to 0.4
angstrom resolution in that work
it's a beautiful thing and being able to
see these materials
has revolutionized what we can do with
them
diamonds and graphite makes me when i
talk about graphite
i get excited i get excited now
i'm working on my arm here so i got to
go up that way
and i got to go this way and
all right hold on hold on let's go that
way
and now wait a second i'm very
excited oh wait there's a lot of noise
i try i gotta work on my arm
it's such a beautiful material
too excited we'll have more
all right
now i don't
i don't mean to bring us down after
why this matters and excitement but you
know here's the thing
if there's one thing you know about
chemistry by now it's that chemistry
lives in the fast lane
and what i mean is they know about the
rules and they also know they're meant
to be broken
and you know lewis is and octets are no
exception
all right and so there are exceptions
to lewis's octet rule
and i'll give you a couple of examples
and it has to do with the concepts that
we've been talking about
but in particular atoms like boron
right boron trifluoride well that one
you know
you could draw it you know if you wanted
to
you could draw it like this and
now let's see here f
and you could do this f right
but the problem with this is then when
you look at the formal charges you've
got a minus one there
and a minus one there and so actually
what this structure does
is boron is like you know what i'm
flexible
i don't need my eight i can be okay with
six
i'll just as long as you keep sharing
fluorine atoms
as long as you keep sharing those those
electrons so we can make these
three covalent bonds all equivalent
i'm okay and so this
is actually and you can see the formal
charges on all the atoms here are zero
this is actually the stable structure
even though boron does not
this does not satisfy the octet rule
chemistry breaking the rules
so boron is said to be happy boron
can be what is called in
this world electron deficient
right and by the same token you can go
the other way and sulfur likes to go the
other way
because sometimes sulfur you know so
there we have
sulfur tetrafluoride so i'm using the
same external atom but sulfur
also prefers to
look like this okay
and to have one extra lone pair there
and now we can go like this and like
that
right like that
and so what sulfur will do oh boy lots
of dots
and so what sulfur will do is it will
form
at what's called an expanded octet
expanded octet and this will become also
a little bit uh you'll we'll sort of
understand this also a little bit more
once we look at
shapes shapes are going to play an
important role in in molecular stability
right um but for now i just wanted you
to know that there are exceptions
to the rules and in particular as you go
beyond the first couple of rows
right so you go down in the periodic
table
you do find atoms more willing like
sulfur to have an expanded octet
in order to reach the the lowest energy
state now in the last two minutes
i come back to this so that's just to
bring it all back home
around lewis and around
electronegativity
and around all these covalent bonding
concepts and what i want to leave you
with is
is is what was kind of the point part of
the point of your goodie bag
you know which is i wanted you to get
your hands on these materials so you
could touch and
feel you know the differences and see
that that actually it's the properties
at the end
that are also very important for
determining what a material is
so you can make rules you know like
you know like electronegativity
difference less than
1.6 is gonna be polar covalent
or nonpolar covalent or greater than two
it's probably ionic
but at the end of the day you got to
come back to properties
right and um you know in ionic solids
in ionic solid i'll put up a slide
showing this but ionic solids are hard
brittle and solid at room temperature
covalent solids can be gases liquids
or solids covalent solids have a low
melting point ionic solids are typically
high
right covalent solids are poor
conductors ionic ones
are usually insulators as a solid this
is what you need to also do
you can't just go by one metric you got
to look at the properties
it's what mendeleev did and it's what
chemists have always done
to make progress okay so on that note
have a great weekend and see you at the
[Applause]
exam
you